mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
abcd is a square
point e is exterior to the square such
that e a is equal to 5 eb is equal to 2
and e c is equal to 4. what is the area
of square abcd
i thank elmer for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
suppose the square has a side length
equal to x
consider the following right triangle
suppose its legs are equal to a and b
by my favorite right triangle theorem we
have a squared plus b squared is equal
to two squared which is equal to four
consider then the following right
triangle
one leg is equal to a plus x and the
other leg is equal to b
therefore where the quantity a plus x
squared plus b squared is equal to 4
squared and that's equal to 16.
we finally have this right triangle
one leg is equal to a and the other leg
is equal to x plus b
we thus have a squared plus the quantity
b plus x squared is equal to 5 squared
and that's equal to 25.
let's now focus on these three equations
consider the middle equation
we first expand it out
now notice we have an a squared plus b
squared
we know that this is equal to 4 so we
can substitute
from here we will solve this equation
for a
we'll subtract 4 from both sides we'll
then subtract x squared from both sides
and then we'll divide both sides by 2x
we thus get what a is equal to in terms
of x
from here we'll do the same thing in
this equation except we'll solve for b
we'll first expand out
we then have a squared plus b squared
and that's equal to 4.
we'll solve this equation for b we'll
subtract 4 from both sides
we'll subtract x squared from both sides
and then we'll divide both sides by 2x
we thus have b in terms of x
we can take these expressions for a and
b and substitute that into the first
equation
we end up with the following equation
we'll first simplify it
and then we'll multiply both sides by 4x
squared
from here we need to solve this equation
for x squared
we know the area of the square is equal
to x squared and we'll let that be equal
to u
let's substitute in
we'll now expand out and then collect
like terms
what we have is a quadratic equation in
u
we can thus use brahmagupta's quadratic
formula to solve for u
we end up with two possibilities
once we simplify this we get something
that's approximately 31.8 and another
possibility that's approximately 9.2
let's now consider these two
possibilities
recall the area is equal to x squared
which is equal to u so substitute back
in for x squared
now recall that a is equal to 12 minus x
squared all over 2x
since we want e to be exterior to the
square we must have a be a non-negative
number
then since the square's side length x is
greater than zero we have x squared is
less than or equal to twelve therefore
we cannot have x squared be
approximately equal to 31.8
we exclude this possibility
we thus have the answer that x squared
or the area is equal to 41 minus the
square root of 511 all over 2 and that's
the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]
you